pour accéder au sud-est de la dominique
il faut passer par le village de
pichelin pendant l'ouragan maria la
rivière qui traverse la commune est
devenue un taureau maisons ponts et
routes ont été balayées aujourd'hui les
véhicules empruntent le lit de la
rivière la reconstruction d'un pont
capable d'affronter de futurs tempête
à peine commencées les villages du sud
atlantique
green bay fond saint jean petit savane
et bagatelles sont coupés du monde sans
téléphone et sans électricité
[Musique]
c'est ici que plus de 500 agriculteurs
vivent exclusivement de la culture de
bois d'haine et de sa transformation en
huile
huit mois après le ragot maria les
arbres qui ont survécu on voit leurs
premières feuilles une récolte se fera
bientôt mais les alambics pour extraire
lui des feuilles sont détruits c'est
toute la filière qui est sinistrée
[Musique]
nous étions sur place en juillet 2010
est cette même distillerie située à
bagatelle était en plein de production
avant l'ouragan maria et la tempête
tropicale erika qui en 2015 a dévasté
cette partie de l'île la dominique et
est le premier producteur mondial de
l'huile de bois d'haine le secteur était
rentable à l'étranger lui de bois dan
vaut de l'or
elle est l'ingrédient de base des
parfums et des cosmétiques
voici l'huile pure en provenance de
l'alambic
voici un livre je vends ça à la
coopérative 30 euros pour 450 g ici j'ai
900 grammes
donc ça vaut 60 euros ici le berom
fabriqué avec lui de bois d'haine est
utilisé dans la caraïbe au calme et les
fièvres et éloigner les moustiques sur
internet
la bouteille de berom se vendent à 13
euros de son pour sont plus chers par
rapport au prix de vente à la dominique
ce marché lucratif a été stoppée depuis
le passage de l'ouragan maria la
coopérative des huiles essentielles qui
regroupe les planteurs de l'est
dominique achète toute la production
d'huile de bois d'haine et la revend sur
place et à l'étranger les locaux situés
à roseaux dans la capitale ont été
endommagés par l'ouragan maria
il n'y a pas d'électricité il est
impossible de travailler les dossiers
sont encore conservés dans des sacs
poubelle aucune aide n'a été accordée
pour reconstruire le secteur si vital
pour l'économie
dans cette réserve située au sous-sol du
bâtiment se trouve les dernières fûts
d'huile de bois d'haine disponible sur
l'île dans la réserve
il n'y a que trois barils d'huile de
bois d'haine trois barils dont chacun
pèse 200 kg acheté environ 60 euros le
kilo donc ça représente 27 gens lisent
manufacturing une compagnie locale qui
fabrique ses propres produits sur place
souhaite racheter l'activité de la
coopérative des huiles essentielles de
la dominique
l'huile de bois d'haine est un
ingrédient essentiel dans l'élaboration
de plusieurs produits fabriqués ici qui
sont vendus à l'étranger et dans les
pharmacies de l'entreprise à il y en a
trois à roseaux un nouveau répulsif
contre les moustiques à base de l'huile
de bois d'haine est déjà populaire
auprès des clients genlis manufacturing
veut contrôler la qualité de l'huile de
bois d'haine sa désormais en voici notre
répulsif contre les insectes
c'est fabriqué à base d'huile de bois
d'inde cultivés ici à la dominique
stein de bois des naix dilué avec de
l'eau et de l'alcool
nous essayons d'acheter notre huile aux
mêmes producteurs vont tester la
production de nos fournisseurs
avant de lâcher les cocoteraies de la
dominique ont été anéanties par
l'ouragan maria ici à ma coucheries
c'est rond et l'état de branche menthe
sont ceux qui restent de cette
plantation de 24 hectares
[Musique]
en juillet 2017 deux mois avant le
passage de marjah cette même cocoteraie
fournissait de la matière première aux
fabricants de l'huile de noix de coco la
demande mondiale procès de l'huile a
augmenté de 500% ces dix dernières
années
à l'époque john fort et un entrepreneur
basé dans le village de coulisses tri
sur la côte caraïbe capitaliser sur la
forte demande dans une cuisine
construite à côté de sa maison y
fabriquait y sont l'huile vierge de noix
de coco d'une manière artisanale
il ne pouvait pas en produire assez pour
satisfaire la demande
[Musique]
il ya un grand marché pour ce produit
la question se pose comment faire sur
une échelle plus importante
il faut de la production de
l'infrastructure il faut que le
gouvernement intervienne toutes ces
choses
l'ouragan maria infliger de lourds
dégâts à john ford
la rivière est entré dans sa maison et
dans son lieu de production d'huile de
noix de coco tout son équipement et son
stock d'huile ont été emportés une perte
de 20 mille euros il ne sait pas à quel
moment il va pouvoir reprendre son
activité
c'est pathétique
toutes les machines pour faire de
l'huile de noix
toute l'opération est parti après
l'ouragan maria des centaines de
personnes sont venues certaines de
l'étranger pour me demander de l'huile
de noix de coco mais il n'y en a pas est
ce qu'on aura des noix de coco la
dominique avant six ou sept ans personne
ne peut prédire la situation on ne sait
pas ce que c'est
[Musique]
le village de colibri porte encore les
séquelles du passage de l'ouragan maria
c'est la rivière qui a fait le plus de
dégâts
le gouvernement veut déplacer les
habitants
c'est la deuxième fois en l'espace de
trois ans que la commune est détruite
[Musique]
avant le passage de l'ouragan maria
toutes sortes de savon étaient fabriqués
dans cette usine fait à base de produits
locaux comme l'huile de noix de coco et
lui de bois d'haine les savons et est
distribué dans les grandes surfaces à la
dominique et exporter vers l'étranger la
savonnerie a connu un fort succès les
étagères était toujours bien folie
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les étagères sont vides
après l'ouragan les pillards ont volé
tous les savons les matières premières
et l'équipement ont été dévalisés
les pertes s'élèvent à 17000 euros
charmant grégoire propriété en des lieux
n'avaient pas d'assurance
c'est ici qu'ils étaient stockés nos
matières premières voici un produit qui
a été pillé il y avait une vingtaine de
bidons ils ont tout pris
c'est notre huile végétale ingrédient
principal pour la fabrication de savon
on avait des fûts comme celui-ci rempli
d'huile de noix de coco ils sont partis
avec tout cela on avait des bidons
d'huiles essentielles
ça a été pillée aussi ils sont partis
avec nos bidons pleins de produits alors
que c'était nos matières premières pour
fabriquer les savons tout à été volés
sont rentrés dans jean charest guagua
utilise ses économies pour redémarrer
malgré les coûts élevés pour importer
toutes ces matières premières à
l'étranger cet entrepreneur ne baisse
pas les bras
c'est notre gagne pain
cette entreprise existe depuis des
années il y un marché pour les produits
nous avons une bonne réputation
l'entreprise est fiable
c'est rentable on gagne bien pas
seulement moi mais mes employés aussi et
le pays et nous sommes passionnés par
notre travail c'est pour ça que nous
allons tout a commencé
[Musique]
aujourd'hui rares sont les visiteurs qui
fréquentent le marché touristique de la
capitale roseaux la plupart des auteurs
sont fermés et peu de paquebots font
escale cette haine rebondeuse de
souvenirs ne font même pas le
déplacement pour les rares bateaux
leurs étals sont vides
[Musique]
ce kiosque tenu par l'association des
entrepreneurs est beau restée fermée
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
laurent goumarre ya a détruit des
produits naturels vendus ici les 25
membres de l'association sont tous
illustrés
avant le cyclone ses clients ce qui
était prisé des visiteurs
toutes sortes de produits naturels
cultivés et transformés à la dominique y
était vendu le moringa les huiles
essentielles les tisanes c'était un
point de vente et dial pour les
herboristes de la dominique
joseph pelletier ici à droite et klaxons
punk funk cultivateurs de moringa et
membre de l'association des herboristes
la route pour se rendre dans leurs
champs est praticable depuis peu ces
septuagénaires
retraité depuis plusieurs années se sont
reconvertis en plantes de moringa il y a
quatre ans
à
[Musique]
sur le terrain les shoots chine et les
vignes de jirau mots se porte bien
mais l'ouragan maria a dévasté le
moringa monsieur 250 pieds il ne reste
que la moitié mais cette essence et
tenance septembre avec les racines à
l'air continue à envoyer des feuilles
même s'ils sont trop et couché par terre
et c'est ça qui est beau c'est une idée
comme ça que j'étais
bonjour vu des bouchons négoce a tué sa
non pas encore parce qu'il pourrait
jouer pour donner à ses forces à ses
cours depuis septembre 2010 est la
production est en arrêt quelques arbres
sont enfin prêts pour une récolte malgré
les pertes en matière première
équipements marchandises et chiffre
d'affaires estimé à 60 mille euros
monsieur shearling fun et monsieur
pelletier veulent recommencer
et j'aime ça et je veux continuer je
suis quelqu'un qui n'aime pas les échecs
j'aime réussir et cette plante a du
potentiel
pas simplement pour faire de l'argent
mais aussi pour montrer aux jeunes que
si tu fais preuve de résilience et de
persévérance
tu peux faire quelque chose de bien tu
n'as pas besoin du gouvernement pour
t'offrir du travail avant l'ouragan
maria la transformation du moringa était
une affaire de famille les enfants et
les petits enfants de joseph patier
séparer les fleurs et les feuilles des
branches
[Musique]
le tour était séché dans des tiroirs
pendant trois jours
oui
après avoir été moulues le moringue en
poudre était tombales et manuellement
par joseph teintier recommandé par les
égouts rist pour soulager l'inflammation
le diabète l'hypertension et le
cholestérol il ya eu une forte demande
pour le moringa de la dominique
l'ouragan maria arracher le 3d salle de
séchage joseph pelletier la réparer et
il a refait les tiroirs il est presque
prêt à redémarrer la transformation de
son moringa today aujourd'hui j'ai
envoyé une première expédition de mort
une gabarre dad
depuis l'ouragan j'avais encore un peu
de matière première mais quand je
commencerai la production avec des
feuilles fraîches
je vais renvoyer à la barbade en
martinique et trinidad et tobago nous
avons pu maintenir en fin de compte
l'intérêt pour notre produit
à watten iphone situé dans les hauteurs
volcanique à l'intérieur de l'île le
ragondin mariant a passé sa colère sur
les bains chauds minéralisés de ty guen
glochos et sur le jardin tropical dont
la fraîcheur a disparu il a fallu des
travaux titanesques pour enlever les
glissements de roche et reconstruire les
bassins six semaines seulement après le
cyclone les premiers clients
on peut se baigner ici à watson wife and
tiguan glochos est la seule station
thermale à ouvrir depuis l'ouragan
la végétation peine à repousser sur les
pentes dans le jardin les travaux sont
en cours pour refaire les manches et
replanter les fleurs
[Musique]
la reconstruction réalisé avec l'aide de
ses amis a épuisé le propriétaire louis
georges il a dépensé toutes ses
économies pour refaire les bains vous
savez nous sommes des gens qui
travaillent en dur on a l'habitude de
vivre dans la misère on a l'habitude de
se battre
donc quand les choses sont dures on est
là on se met au travail
cet ouragan est passé en l'espace de
quelques heures mais nous avions pris
des années pour construire tigana
blocher tu sais on lui pendant 16 17 18
ans et voir tout cela on porte en
l'espace de quelques heures
c'est dur donc tout le monde doit faire
comme noah tieghem tu ne peux pas rester
à attendre l'intervention d'un
gouvernement comme ça tu ne peux pas
attendre les gens mais avec l'amour à
qu'on partage les gens rognent raid et
on va s'en sortir
le faut
[Musique]
à
avant l'ouragan maria plusieurs lieux
comme tiguan glochos proposer des bains
chauds les clients en quête de bien-être
prenez des eaux et se détendent est dans
la nature
enbridge qui ici depuis son enfance il
connaît les bienfaits des eaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a des pouvoirs de guérison en fait
où est l'eau souffre on file à travers
la terre à travers les roches et les
racines et lorsque des marges sur la
surface de la terre et les puissants
tous les jours il reprenait ses forces
dans l'eau glacée et dont les bains
chauds
[Musique]
les clients de l ridge venez également
poussé à mettre naturel distillées dans
différentes bouteilles de rhum
[Musique]
c'est maintenant l'heure du bois bandé
vous en voulez si vous voulez je vous
donne un petit peu un c'est bon pour la
circulation du sang d'ailleurs ces
flacons d'huiles de serpents étaient
très recherchées par les visiteurs de la
menthe unique et de la guadeloupe
l'huile soulagerait les articulations
[Musique]
français prend tout coup dès qu'il
s'agit d'huile de serpents si ces
bouteilles que vous voyez la ville de
noix de coco c'était de lui aussi à
point ils auraient tous puis de
langoureux cette petite taille souvent
16 euros et 10 c par décennie
[Musique]
et guérir les ravages infligés à la
dominique prendra des années
la force de la nature en finir en pas
pansé les plaies laissées par l'ouragan
maria les hommes et les femmes affecté
physiquement et mentalement par le
cyclone maria mais qui croient encore en
l'avenir de leur ils braveront les
incertitudes du climat pourrait
construire la dominique
[Musique]